are you real are you real are you real  eletronic there's quite a few disneyland  urban legends that have stuck around  Walt Disney being cryogenically frozen  there's a dome over the park to control  the atmosphere the one myth turned out  to be absolutely true Johnny Depp's  sometimes shows up on the Pirates of the  Caribbean ride  [Music]  [Applause]  Wednesday night Jack Sparrow himself  surprised Disneyland guests completely  in character I'm so sorry were you still  talking this perfectly coincides with  the building hype for the upcoming  sequel pirates of the caribbean dead men  tell no tales in theaters May 26  [Music]  Oh  [Music]